hi my name is Alan Glickenhaus I'm the
IBM API business strategist probably the
question I'm asked more than any other
one is what's the difference between
api's and services this is especially
asked by those people who have spent the
last 10 or 15 years working on
service-oriented architecture and
services so I thought we'd record a
video and just finally answer this
question once and for all and I threw in
micro services as well which is a new
topic that's come up that we get asked a
lot about the positioning as well so
first of all from an API perspective so
this is our definition chart for API as
we talk about API is application
programming interfaces and really the
term we should be using is business
api's or web api's we're distinguishing
business api from the traditional
technical api that has been around for
decades these are business assets that
we want to make available in a
self-service manner for a particular
audience and so we want to package these
assets up as a consumable entity that we
call the business api and market this to
an audience which is an app developer
that's going to consume this api and use
it so business api is the context of
what we're talking about with api's my
previous role at IBM I was on the
service-oriented architecture came for
IBM and I use this chart a lot and so we
talked about a service as being a
repeatable business task something like
check customer credit open a new account
and so that sounds a lot like what I
just said in API ones and so there's a
little bit of obvious reason why there
might be some confusion in fact it gets
worse if you look at what we were doing
with SOA and services we mostly were
using soap but in the more modern times
have started to use rest there as well
in API is we most often use rest but we
could also use soap the purpose for an
API I said was to exposed a business
asset as an API and for a service we
said to is encapsulate a repeatable
business task as a service which sounds
very similar and do they both do
integration tasks yes they do so so this
is what's causing the confusion and it's
pretty easy to see why that someone
was very familiar with SOA and services
might be confused by api's and isn't it
something that they've already done and
maybe this is just a new name for the
same thing in fact what we've done is
just look at what they have in common
let's take a look at maybe some of the
things that are different right so in
the SOA world the focus was on
connectivity and Reeves
we were building these services to drive
reuse of these services so we had a
single view of an entity a single view
of a customer or single view of an
account a single view of an order and
anyone who wanted the information about
that particular asset would come and
reuse that and then we focused a lot on
the connectivity of the different
services in that in that environment
typically inside the enterprise dealing
with the systems of record the sharing
was about effectiveness and cost were
going to reduce the cost of future
projects that we did in the enterprise
and most of the audience that we were
targeting the services for internal if
we did make the services available to a
few partners it was difficult to do that
we had to set up the security and do
some training for them to consume this
this particular service and so it was
not something we could do for the masses
and the encapsulation aspect was about
less the change we were going to change
what maybe was behind that service
interface and we wouldn't have to change
all the consumers of that which is again
back to the cost issue the focus for API
is is about consumption and speed to
deliver it's about reaching new markets
and the audience is internal but it's
more often and going to be a larger
number of external users so while we
might start with internal the focus is
to get these assets out there to a much
larger external community and it's
really about less to learn and speed and
consumption and that's really the focus
for api's so if you think about these
things working together the systems of
record that are running at each of our
businesses today are critical systems
that can't go down meet high
availability high security we're going
to have robust connectivity capabilities
and that was done through an enterprise
service bus like the IBM integration bus
big level of focus on governance to be
sure that we got the services right and
that we didn't change them without
concern for all the things that we're
consuming them possibly breaking if we
made a
change without testing it correctly so
systems a record absolutely critical to
not go down high security needs lots of
governance now it won't come things like
mobile and social and big data and
analytics and these things are moving at
an incredible rate of speed and I can't
change the systems of record at that
kind of rate of speed so to solve this
problem and let the business do the
things that they need to do quickly
we're going to encapsulate these systems
of record services as self-service API
is that someone could sign up for and
consume themselves we're going to
predefined the security aspects in the
terms and conditions around that and
make that available through an audience
and a secure gateway that'll access
these back-end systems and so the idea
here is that the API is and services do
work together they're not one is a
replacement for the other and the api's
will be accessing the services from the
systems of record but we can change
these things and we can create them on a
much more rapid basis and make these
things available in a self-service
manner so let's look at what these
things have in different I have as
differences and not just what they have
in common so most of the time people who
worked on services or provider oriented
services based on the system of record
if you had a customer system that had
customer data they might be one or more
customer services that people would
access and if you needed customer
information you would come to the
customer service so it was a provider
oriented service same thing for the
account for the inventory for the
shipping system any of these systems
might have services that represented
what the system did and those would be
services that you would access to access
those back-end systems of record the API
is our consumer focused and if you think
about what a consumer might do with the
back-end services they will access
potentially more than one service in a
scenario for example where I want to
check my order status I might have to
check the customer service I might have
to check the inventory service I might
check the system the the shipping
service all in one API call and not have
three separate api's for that person to
do that so one consumer oriented API
might call three or more back-end
services to come up with the answer from
an integration perspective while they
both do integration
away and services were very focused on
integration and had a complete robust
set of connectivity capabilities
integration is not really the primary
focus of api's we want to take an API
call and get it into the backend as
quickly as possible
it's about securing that and making it
perform very well and and and making it
consumable it's not about complex
integration we do need to do some
integration to get the API call to the
backend and so that minimal amount is
done as part of the API solution why do
you care connectivity and reuse is what
we talked about for services
self-service consumption security
analytics and speed for API s and
finally for services the focuses for
governance is very strong and for API is
it's really just enough we need to be
able to move very fast in the API space
to get to market very quickly so there
is a difference in perspectives and use
cases for API as far as the services
really the best scenario is that we're
using these together so three questions
lead to good API is the first question
you want to ask yourself when you're
thinking about what API you want to
create is who is the audience what what
what audience are we talking about is
this an internal user that is going to
build a mobile app or use it somewhere
inside the enterprise is a partner I
mean making a public API the second
question probably the most important one
is what do they want so we're focusing
on that consumer what do they want not
what do you have we're not going to put
an API in front of every service that we
have and just say to the audience you
figure out how to make these things work
together the better API is are going to
be consumer oriented and map to my
potentially multiple back-end services
it might be the case that we're going to
call one one back-end service and that's
fine
but let's not focus on what we have as
the things that are driving the API
creation and then the third question
that we're going to ask is under what
terms and conditions are we willing to
share and this deals with the security
around the API who's authorized to use
it and also the policies around the API
rate limits how many times per minute
our second whatever it is that we want
to make it available and so we'll
understand what conditions we want to
make this available to them and that's
what leads to good API so after we've
answered these questions of course
then we have to build the API and we're
going to map that what do they want to
the what do we have but that's not
something that should drive the creation
of the API itself so let's talk a little
bit about how micro services fit into
this traditionally every project that
we've done for the history of computing
has three components to it there's some
kind of a user interaction in some way
whether it's user interface or something
that a user is going to interface with
the new project to tell you what they
want to do there's going to be some kind
of business logic that they deal with
that is going to make the decisions on
what should happen and then maybe some
data manipulation on the backend some
updates or some reads that are going to
get done to access and massage the data
in some way and as we did these projects
we thought about it from an antenna
perspective and we delivered that
project as a whole and that would take a
certain amount of time to deliver
whatever amount that was we needed all
the parts to come together to deliver
the project successfully with micro
services what we're going to do is do
the exact same thing but we're going to
break it up into the component parts so
each one of the parts the user interface
the business logic and the data
manipulation can be built separately by
individual teams on a separate schedule
with the idea that these will be working
together but also that others might use
them as well so if you think about this
a mobile app let's say is being created
has a user interface it's going to call
in and do some business logic and do
some data manipulation and maybe that's
the first solution you come out with but
the second solution might have the
partner doing something that's going to
invoke that same business logic and that
same data manipulation in this case you
don't only use your interface someone
else does and you can come to market
much quicker if you built this on micro
services as an architectural style
rather than as a whole monolithic
project and really that's what the trend
would microservices is let's think about
the components that we can build
together in consumable ways so that we
can do projects faster and still get
great results for the enterprise so how
does that work with api's so the micro
services can be built either in the
systems of record or in front of the
systems of record based on your needs
and add the business logic for the you
interface if you want to do that there
for the business logic and for the data
manipulation and then you'll control the
access to the micro service through an
API layer that makes that micro service
consumable by the audience that you want
to consume it so if you're making it
available initially to the internal
developers for the mobile app with the
web that's great and then you want to
make an API available to your partner to
consume that same business logic that's
fine too and you can have different
terms and conditions for each audience
and so really that's how API is and
micro services will work together with
the services in the systems of record to
provide a complete solution and it gives
us tremendous amount of flexibility
it gives us the control and the
availability for the systems of record
while giving us the speed and
consumption and security that we want
from a an API layer and so think of an
API as a managed micro service and
you're good to go for bringing these
things to market hopefully that helped
to answer this question once or for all
I'm sure it's not the last time I'll be
answering it but I'll be pointing people
to this video so they can see the answer
for positioning api's and services and
micro services Thanks